mich hat heute ein Thema aufgeregt und
zwar habe ich eine Studie gelesen von
der Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung und wenn
Sie das jetzt für einen werden sie zu
Hause zum Glauben dass es ein Scherz was
die blonde Frau da erzählt ist es nicht
denn jeder fünfte Deutsche also genau
genommen 22% der Deutschen wollen keinen
Kontakt mit suv-fahrern haben das muss
man sich wirklich mal auf der Zunge
zergehen lassen das also jeder fünfte
Deutsche möchte Kontakt zu suv-fahrern
meiden das ist aber leider kein Scherz
und was mich noch schockiert hat und die
politische Polarisierung in unserem Land
im Blick auf das Klima zeigt ist jeder
fünfte gab auch an er wolle mit
klimaaktivisten persönlich nicht zu tun
haben also 22% wollen mit SUV-Fahrer
nicht zu tun haben und dann will jeder
fünfte nichts mit klimaaktivisten zu tun
haben wir sehen also zwei sehr strikte
Lager ich bin dafür wir sollten sowohl
mit suv-fahrern als auch ein
klimakaktivisten Kontakt haben können es
zeigt die gesellschaftliche Spaltung ich
wünsche mir in der Klimadebatte wenig
weniger Ideologie und endlich mehr
Pragmatismus
absolut richtig Liebe Nena also das
zeigt einfach dem Zeitgeist wir sehen
die Gesellschaft ist gespalten egal ob
FC Bayern München und Dortmund egal ob
impfen oder ungeimpft oder SUV-Fahrer
oder lastenradfahrer sind auch
Nebenkriegsschauplätze wir haben ganz
andere Probleme eigentlich sollten wir
Brücken bauen Brücken das Miteinander
aufeinander zugehen nicht nebeneinander
leben sondern miteinander leben und
momentan ist es nur noch aufgeheizt mein
echauffiert sich ist eine
erregungsgesellschaft und man versucht
immer den Fehler beim anderen zu finden
es gibt kein diskuss mehr keine
Debattenkultur mehr und keinen
aufeinander zugehen und daran krank
unsere komplette Gesellschaft aber auch
natürlich der der Diskurs der
pluralistischen Gesellschaft leider
mache ich immer die Gegend keine Sorge
also Hessen sich am Astronaut so habe
ich mir so ein SUV gekauft ich habe mir
einen Land Rover Defense einer von uns
am Tisch eigentlich jetzt sagen
wenn ihr in diesem falschen Film dabei
seid damit den nein nein ich kann also
für SUV Fahrer muss ich die Hand ins
Feuer legen da ich auch kleiner bin nein
also ganz klar als trotz fahre ich so
ein Auto wobei ich ob es mit 44
angefangen Auto zu fahren meine CO2
Bilanz ist makellos aber jetzt der Punkt
nein ich kenne die These stimmt
natürlich die sieben
natürlich mit dieser ganzen mit diesem
Getöse aber das ist natürlich auch
Demokratie wenn das wir jetzt solche
Debatten haben solche
Auseinandersetzungen bei mir bei Corona
beim Klima das finde ich auf eine das
ist doch fantastisch das sind
Lebenszeichen der Demokratie da wird
dann auch mal stilistisch überfordert da
ist man nicht in meiner verliert man
etwas die Nerven die Contenance okay
aber das wird diese Debatte haben ist
doch etwas Großartiges weil wenn man das
nicht hat dann kommen dann die
TV-Experten und sagen so jetzt ist die
Politik Verdrossenheit jetzt gehen die
Leute nicht mehr wählen sie gehen nicht
mehr abstimmen ich glaube wir haben
heute tatsächlich so eine Reihe von
wichtigen Weichenstellungen da gehört
natürlich diese ganze Klima Debatte dazu
wie will man die Lösung mit
marktwirtschaftlichen metho damit dieser
Kommandowirtschaft wie wir es bei Corona
erleben was ist da der richtige Weg wir
wissen natürlich was der richtige Weg
wäre
nur kurz das sind doch auch gute
Lebenszeichen der Demokratie und
vielleicht trauen wir den mal nach wenn
dann wieder was der russische Körper
sagt absolut richtig wir sind wir
Deutschland wacht gerade ein bisschen
auf nach diesem 16-Jährigen Schlaf kann
man fast sagen die mobilisierungsschlaf
den wir hatten Dornröschenschlaf kann
man ja auch in den Dornröschen Angela
das war ja plötzlich Streit galt ja
irgendwie als etwas Schlechtes hatte man
fast in einem auch der Streit um das
richtige Argument da wurde dann einfach
gesagt gewisse Dinge sind alternativlos
haltet die Klappe auf deutsch gesagt
redet nicht weiter drüber und legt euch
wieder hin oder setzt euch auf die Couch
es Chips und
reingemacht
bei der Kanzlerin ihrer Partei aber ein
Punkt möchte ich dann einmal machen beim
Thema Klimaschutz ich glaube das was sie
sagen da ist ganz ganz vieles drin was
mich eigentlich stört an der Debatte ist
dass sie natürlich komplett ideologisch
geführt dass man eigentlich viel zu
wenig auf Fakten schaut wenn ich mir
anschaue das Ende dieses Jahres drei der
letzten sechs und Ende nächsten Jahres
die letzten drei Kernkraft Meiler vom
Netz genommen werden und dann bis 2030
idealerweise in der Koalition die sie
als Mitte Linksbündnis bezeichnet haben
dann die Kohlekraftwerke vom letzten
überall coole Kraftwerke vom Netz gehen
soll dann müssen wir uns einmal nur
anschauen wie viel Energie wir an einem
Tag wie heute eigentlich genau von
diesen
Stromerzeuger bekommen wir haben heute
an einem zum Teil sonnigen Tag im
November der ist ein bisschen sonnig
gewesen bisschen windstillen in
Deutschland ein Strommix gehabt und 13
Uhr
68% konventionelle Energie bedeutet rund
40 Prozent Kohle
11,8% oder knapp 12 Prozent Kernkraft ja
bei 52 Prozent der Rest mit Gas
aufgefüllt das heißt wir liegen bei 68%
mehr als zwei Drittel konventionell und
wir wollen uns dieser ganzen dem größten
Teil dieser Strom Lieferanten jetzt
selbst berauben um dann zu sagen liebe
Polen Liebe Franzosen liefert uns doch
bitte euren dreckigen Kohlestrom euren
teuren Atomstrom was auch immer das ist
doch lieber Chaya sie müssen
wirklich perverse Energiepolitik und das
eine verlogene Debatte über die wird
nämlich
da wir können über diese Energie Frage
gerne diskutieren da sind sie bei der
CDU glaube ich auch richtig aber ja zu
Atomkraft halt bisher nicht gehört ich
auch nicht sagen Sie mal ich würde gerne
zu der Weg nein Frage von Nina
zurückkommen und das war die Frage haben
wir eine zunehmende
Radikalisierung in der Gesellschaft auch
von scheinbaren Minderheiten Positionen
also übertreiben wir an vielen Stellen
mein Plädoyer für große Volksparteien
dass sie auch noch retten darf weil da
die Diskussion intern stattfindet und
nicht der Ausgleich von wenigen
kleinstmeinungen manche sagen ja auch
von
übergroßen Minderheiten jedenfalls
lauten Minderheiten die dann Koalition
bilden aber die eigentlich nicht mehr
die Breite der Gesellschaft abbilden
wenn gleichzeitig die Mehrheit der
Deutschen sagt man darf nicht mehr sagen
was man denkt
dass das gibt ja Korrelation zwischen
diesen beiden Themen das eine ist eine
Radikalisierung von
minderheitenmeinungen und gleichzeitig
eine Mehrheit die sagt dass normale
Leben darf man nicht mehr ansprechen in
normalen Themen unter anderem auch die
Frage wäre es nicht sinnvoller gewesen
die Atomkraft beizubehalten und die und
die Braunkohle und Steinkohlekraftwerke
eher abzuschalten
es gibt das finde ich natürlich nicht
ganz zu es gibt nicht nur eine
Radikalisierung der Minderheit nicht
beobachte auch eine Radikalisierung des
Mainstreams eine Radikalisierung der
etablierten Politik also wenn mir die
Leute die Politiker Befehlen dass ich
wenn ich einen Restaurant gehen will
dass ich da mich zuerst zertifizieren
lassen muss oder möglich noch einen was
auch immer mich impfen lassen muss also
körperliche Unversehrtheit dann
beobachten wir natürlich auch eine
Radikalisierung der etablierten Politik
und diese Radikalisierung produziert
natürlich dann auch radikale
Gegenreaktion und da gefällt mir etwas
diese unschuldsrätorik die sie
allerdings sehr überzeugende vorgetragen
haben die gefällt mir nicht so ganz die
Blende für mich etwas die Seite aus
vielleicht sogar die Ursache dieser
Radikalisierung der Minderheit ist
vielleicht die Radikalisierung der CDU
die Radikalisierung der Mitte
meine Güte das sind aber viele Themen
Deutsch champions league champions
League
für die Politik der Mitte stehen wir
schon noch aber die entscheidende Frage
ist doch habe ich diese Einzelposition
alle in einem Parlament oder haben wir
noch Volksparteien ich weiß nicht ob ihr
in der Schweiz noch Volksparteien habt
ganz wir haben noch ein bisschen höhere
Wähleranteile aus die CD aber ich glaube
ihr seid eine unterbewertete Aktie ihr
kommt wieder also ich bin ganz
zuversichtlich nach der heutigen Sendung
da bin ich guter Dinge nein aber ich
glaube die Diskussion innerhalb von
Organisationen und wir erleben das ja
überall wir haben nicht mehr die großen
in verbindenden Gesellschaften das haben
wir bei Gewerkschaften nicht bei Kirchen
nicht bei Parteien nicht sondern es
bilden sich sehr viele kleine
individualgruppen und davon sind einige
sehr laut und werden sehr schnell
ohne Wissen radikal und da haben wir aus
meiner Sicht kein politisches
Gegengewicht dazu dass diese Dinge dann
auch in vernünftiger Weise diskutiert
werden soll ich gebe Ihnen Recht Politik
läuft dann häufig dem Mainstream an
unterschiedlichen Entscheidung jeder
fünfte deutsch ist radikal weil wir
wollen ja 22% kein Kontakt mit SUV
fahren dann wäre jede für jeder fünfte
radikal das wäre ein Armutszeugnis für
unser Land nein ich würde nicht sagen
jeder fünfte ist radikal aber wir
erleben eine Radikalisierung von
Minderheiten Positionen und dass man
dann auch immer stärker in diese Blase
rutscht und da auch gar nicht mehr
herauskommt weil man auch gar keine
anderen Informationen mehr wahrnimmt und
die Frage ist habe ich in irgendeiner
Form ein Gegengewicht um mal mit den
Fakten die Lage zu reflektieren und zu
sagen so und so sind die Dinge und dann
wird man auch nicht gleich so radikal
sondern etwas ruhiger